[Musique]
après ce reportage là parce que
personnage que vous voyez là dans cette
publicité des M&M suscite la controverse
auprès de la droite américaine aimée au
point la polémique est tellement
importante que la compagnie a décidé de
suspendre suspendre même les personnages
ou suspens de publicité les personnages
féminins alors c'est toute une histoire
oui exactement je vais vous expliquer
pourquoi toute une histoire que
commencer au mois de septembre dernier
avec l'arrivée du personnage violet
baptisé purple troisième personnage
féminin du groupe de ces bonbons M&M's
le violet notamment qu'il symbole du
soutien à la communauté LGBTQ alors la
compagnie la société mère a été accusée
de politiser ces personnages c'est le
propos de plusieurs présentateurs de Fox
News notamment Tucker callsin qui
s'inquiète aussi du personnage vert
également féminin qui l'a qualifié de
lesbiennes et donc il pour lui ces
personnages sont tous walk à mélange de
critiques à cet égard ce qu'il souhaite
en fait que calcin c'est que tous ces
bonhommes ces bonbons M&M soit androgyne
sans référence au genre nouvelle
contreverses qui a été
suscité encore une fois l'indignation
date du mois de janvier alors elle est
toute récente c'est l'apparition de
cette emballage on voit encore une fois
les personnages féminins le vert le
mauve le brun on les voit en vert parce
que le message qui est inscrit sur ce
paquet c'est de célébrer les femmes qui
renversent le statut quo alors nouvelle
vague de critique à l'égard de la
compagnie qui a partagé une déclaration
sur ses réseaux sociaux en réponse à ces
critiques et je vous cite quelques-uns
de ces passages on peut lire notamment
américain parlons entre nous l'année
dernière nous avons amené quelque chose
changement nos personnages et nous ne
pensions pas qu'il briserait l'internet
c'est ce qui est arrivé de tout évidence
et on peut lire également ceci nous
avons décidé de mettre les personnages
sur pause pour un temps est terminée
pour les remplacer nous sommes fiers de
présenter une nouvelle porte-parole
c'est Maya Rudolf cette comédienne bien
connue bien appréciée du public
américain que l'on a vu notamment dans
saturing Night Live et qu'on devrait
voir par ailleurs une première fois lors
d'une publicité qui va jouer pendant le
superbow qui arrive à très grand pas et
vraiment la preuve que c'est une roue
qui tourne sans fin c'est que même cette
décision de retirer les personnages
américains suscitent elles aussi une
contreverse alors on verra bien ce qui
va se passer de ce côté si Eminem va
décider de ramener ces personnages mais
pour le moment retrait momentané de leur
publicité
merci aimé au revoir pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez-vous sur la
chaîne ici RDI